the return to work Anna Manchester a new
way of commuting roads are being given
over to cyclists and pedestrians safer
than crowding together on public
transport and a win for the planet new
research shows carbon emissions dropped
17 million tons a day at the peak of the
global lock down to levels last seen in
2006 instead of the priority being the
economy whatever that is the priority
should be how we all want to live and
what we want to make a better world to
live in and and it's so much nicer this
cycle this is the nicest cycle ride I
have ever done to work the economy's
gotta run people of God still got to use
the cars occasionally I mean I can't
bring a wardrobe back from Ike here on
my bike by the end of April the total
reduction in carbon emissions as a
result of the pandemic was estimated to
be just over 1 billion tons that
compares to the total for 2019 of 37
billion tons Surface Transport such as
car journeys accounted for 43 percent of
the fall emissions from industry and
power another 43 percent aviation the
industry hardest hit by the coronavirus
actually accounted for just 10% of the
drop the drops and emissions we see now
they're unlikely to last and they won't
do much at all I mean in fact nothing to
slow climate change we really need much
larger efforts to really move away from
fossil energy transform everything into
renewable energy and use less energy in
the future despite the lockdown the
atmosphere is still on course this year
to reach the highest carbon dioxide
level in two million years if economic
activity restarts in mid-june carbon
emissions for 2020 will be 4 percent
lower than last year barely a blip in
the long term upward trend it shows just
how much the economy needs to be
transformed to cut out carbon for good
and hold back global warming even
individual things that people do like
not driving or not flying so much
although it has some impact you need to
change things at the system level the
whole thing needs to change to get away
from using fossil fuels if we
1az seriously have an impact on the
build of a co2 in the atmosphere and
stop it building up governments are now
rebooting their economies and there's a
choice look back to fossil fuels or
forwards to jobs that could come by
investing in green growth Thomas More
Sky News